bonjour il ya quelques années j'étais
dans un parc avec mon fils donc je le
tenait par la main et on se promener
dans le parc d'oslo je vis en norvège et
je marchais avec lui alors imaginez
l'automne les feuilles qui tombent par
millions ou milliards je sais pas un
tapis orange et jaune sur le sol
magnifique et et mon fils émile s'arrête
à un moment il se tourne vers moi l'air
très concentré un papa comment font les
feuilles pour remonter sur les arbres
voyez la question n'est ce pas
incroyable la capacité des enfants à
poser des questions il cherche à
explorer le monde à comprendre le monde
et pour cela ils apprennent à marcher
environ un an
ils apprennent à parler en deux trois
ans et y pose des tas de questions et
une question que personnellement je me
suis posée c'est pourquoi certains
sujets résistent à ces super machine à
apprendre
peut-être vous avez en tête déjà le
sujet je vais vous présenter une petite
image
alors certains auront des sueurs froides
des mauvais souvenirs
attention voilà ceci est une équation
rationnelle
oui pourquoi les mathématiques sont
elles si difficile à apprendre pour nos
enfants
pourquoi et bien j'étais prof
il ya longtemps et j'ai passé quelques
années à essayer de comprendre pourquoi
les enfants n'arrivent pas à apprendre
les maths alors qu'ils sont super
puissant et j'ai fait un travail sur moi
même pas une psychanalyse mais juste
être à l'écouté et de façon curieuse
peut-être je sais pas la barrière à ma
propre compréhension des enfants c'était
moi même être à l'écouté c'est facile à
dire mais c'est difficile à faire et
j'ai dû tuer en quelque sorte le
professeur de mathématiques en moi mais
face est complètement pour comprendre
comment les enfants apprenaient et je
suis arrivé à une petite liste de dix
points et on va aller rapidement à
travers cette liste c'est parti
aucune motivation qui sait pourquoi on
apprend les maths franchement mais moi
en tant que prof de maths je peux pas
l'expliquer presque c'est trop compliqué
le langage mathématique c'est un langage
qui a été réalisé par des experts à
travers des siècles des millénaires il
est super précis super con si rigoureux
il est fantastique pour des experts mais
est ce le bon langage pour les enfants
peut-être pas beaucoup de bla bla bla
bah oui vous étiez en classe vous
souvenez quand vous dormiez reçu vers le
radiateur trop de blabla les enfants les
enfants 3 4 5 mais tout le temps on
n'apprend pas juste avec notre esprit on
apprend avec notre corps on a besoin de
manipuler et les manipulations
il y en a pas franchement beaucoup en
cours de mathématiques et il n'y a pas
vraiment beaucoup de feedback je sais
pas si vous vous souvenez quand vous
étiez à l'école vous aviez des
interrogations beaucoup d'efforts ou pas
d'efforts parce que vous aviez tout
simplement abandonnée ça arrive et et
combien de temps on attendait avant
d'avoir le résultat un jour non une
semaine deux semaines trois semaines des
fois quatre semaines c'est pas du feed
backs penser aux enfants qui apprennent
qu'ils apprennent à parler bugs un couac
est ce que tu dis biberon il ya une
interaction vous voyez et ça ça a
disparu complètement à l'école y'a pas
de feedback ya pas d'exploration les
enfants ils veulent découvrir pourquoi
les feuilles à le montrent la plus
d'exploration pose plus de questions et
le rythme si vous décrochez d'un court
ça vous c'est certainement arriver qu'on
soit bon ou mauvais élèves on décroche
toujours un moment donné parce qu'on
fait pas attention
et là on rame c'est horrible ça va pas
votre rythme c'est pas naturel ça et pas
d'imagination pas de rêve
par contre une chose qu'on a dans les
cours de maths et pas que les cours de
maths c'est des notes vous souvenez des
notes
quand je dis que je suis prof de maths
j'ai des gens qui me disent qu'ils font
encore des cauchemars à l'âge de 45 ans
c'est fou mais qu'est ce qu'on fait avec
nous mêmes c'est n'importe quoi
et aussi de la compet et toi tu as eu
combien j'ai eu trois halls nul vous
souvenez de ça va lui 18 super fort
brillant la grosse illusion les gars
qu'on est bonne note il croit qu'ils
sont plus intelligents que les grecs
bref ouais alors c'est une longue liste
super 10 points c'est énorme
comment les enfants même s'ils sont
super smart comment ils peuvent
apprendre les maths on leur donne aucune
manière naturelle d'apprendre pas de
questions pas de corps rien alors c'est
dur mais je veux pas être pessimiste
aujourd'hui et je vais plutôt venir avec
une bonne nouvelle parce que quand j'ai
vu cette liste après trois ans
d'observation dans les classes 1
motivation feedback instantané
exploration avant - vous dites c'est
quoi ça
en fait vous avez deviné il ya une
activité qui nous permettrait de
surmonter tous ces obstacles une
activité à laquelle adhère la plupart
des jeunes aujourd'hui vous avez une
idée
le jeu vidéo le jeu vidéo on est motivé
on agit c'est génial
et quand j'ai découvert ça je me suis
dit oh ben on va changer le costume de
profs avec la casquette d'entrepreneur
et on va essayer de faire des jeux
d'apprentissage et avec une petite
équipe de programmeurs de designers
d'illustrateurs on a fait des jeux
depuis 2011 pour apprendre les maths et
je vais vous en montrer un maintenant et
on va faire un petit jeu vous allez
essayer de deviner qu'est ce que c'est
vous êtes prêts c'est parti c'est un jeu
de cartes est ce que vous voyez il ya un
écran il ya deux zones
vous les voyez les deux zones bon alors
vous est ce que vous voyez des lucioles
et une caisse
le but du jeu c'est d'isoler la caisse
que la caisse soit tout seul d'un des
deux côtés allez les matins ils ont
compris ce que c'était peut-être chez
pain et vous voyez des poissons et
voyant bas on a un deck avec des cartes
cdc des cartes qu'on peut utiliser pour
pour résoudre le niveau alors les
poissons il faut que j'élimine le
poisson bleu à côté de ma caisse n'est
ce pas et donc je vais utiliser une
règle qui est assez simple c'est que les
poissons il y a des antilles poissons
pour les éliminer envoyez la carte du
décalage la retourne j'ai un anti
poisson vous voyez là en bas et puis je
vais le mettre des deux côtés des zones
c'est une règle du jeu il ya que quatre
règles en fait au début
ouf je le mets la voyez là puis je
prends une autre carte je la mets de
l'autre côté donc poissons et anti
poisson ça s'élimine attention je
l'aimais ensemble ça fait un petit
tourbillon et le côté poisson anti
poisson tourbillon et là j'ai gagné
vous avez suivi le jeu là est une pièce
je la mets tout seul j'ai gagné alors
ces règles que je vous ai donné les
enfants il arrive à les apprendre dans
ce jeu vidéo en si peu de temps
sans explication sans blabla tout
simplement
alors ce que vous avez devinez de quoi
il s'agit les poissons ah ben si on si
on les appelait à et la petite carotte
jaune à aller b et la caisse comme par
hasard j'aurais pu choisir ce que je
veux mais je vais dire x voyez où je
veux en venir je pense là et puis il ya
des cartes qui sont dans une sorte de
cette zone là c'est une sorte de somme
alors je mets un petit plus
et puis pourquoi pas un petit égales
entre les deux zones
un franchement et là on se retrouve avec
je crois que c'est une équation c'est de
l'algèbre a + b égal à +6 ben on va
résoudre ça avec les règles que les
enfants l'ont apprise en quelques
minutes c'est parti je tourne la carte
j'ai lentilles poisson c'est à dire
l'opposé de a - a
je le mets des deux côtés aller et là et
à et moins arr baisse a fait un
tourbillon je l'aimais ensemble et le
tourbillon c zéro et 0 plus bcbg zéro +
6 c x et bats x et galbées vous avez
suivi là
[Applaudissements]
alors je vous montre un petit peu
quelques niveaux très rapidement dans le
jeu parce qu'on s'arrête pas juste avec
ses petites règles on utilise des règles
avec la multiplication la division les
changements de paramètres
voilà on élimine les monstres et à la
fin du jeu vous avez que des lettres et
à la fin même pas de carton on élimine
un petit peu les cartes pour se
rapprocher du formalisme classique voilà
dans un jeu vidéo et les enfants y kif
il adore vous pouvez me demander jean
baptiste est sympa ton truc magique là
est ce que ça marche
et bien oui ouais ça marche on a fait
une petite expérience on a une grande
expérience avec cinquante mille enfants
papa 2 pas 10 50 milles avec
l'université de l'état de washington
et on a découvert qu'en moyenne ça
prenait à peu près 42 minutes
d'apprendre à résoudre une équation
algébrique de premier degré dragon ball
salle g brassens et le nom du jeu 42
minutes bam
c'est pas fou ça et parfois on reçoit
des vidéos youtube de parents qui ne
disent que leurs enfants de 4-5 ans
résolvent des équations
non seulement ça va plus vite mais en
plus c'est accessible à encore plus de
gens parce que c'est un jeu les maths
c'est un jeu et on a révélé un petit peu
le jeu des maths quelque part là alors
oui les maths ça a l'air vachement
compliqué mais en réalité
peut-être pas tant que ça et si vous
croyez que vous êtes nuls en maths ou
que vos enfants sont nuls en maths ou
que vos élèves sont nuls en maths
ben c'est pas vrai le problème c'est
qu'on vous a pas enseigné les maths
correctement merci
[Applaudissements]